and Jacob got it because now notice
notice what he goes on to say he says
all right then he goes okay then what is
your name then jaob please tell me your
name now you normally created angels
angels that are created we'll tell you
I'm Michael Gabriel right but he says to
him why do you ask my name what he means
is why do you ask about my nature it's
beyond
comprehension no matter what I tell you
you won't be able to fully comprehend
who I am and what I'm capable of and so
then Jacob realized wow this was God who
appeared as a man and I wrestled with
him and he blessed him there that's when
Jacob received the blessing you see the
story it wasn't when Isaac blessed them
God doesn't bless you in sin God doesn't
honor you in sin it's here that he
received the blessing that God had
promised for Jacob when he was in his
mother's womb
everyone got it before I move on because
I want to make sure everyone else is
getting
this and then he realizes who the man is
so Jacob named the place panil panil
means face of God pan eel the face of
eel for i' for he said I have seen God
face to face yet my life has been
delivered now which person of the God
had did he
wristle Jesus yes but how do we know
because I'm going to show you the
parallel you
ready Hosea 122 to5 mentions this
wrestling match Hosea 12 2 to5 notice
who is the god that appeared as a man
that wrestled with him who is the god
that appeared as a man that wrestled
with him right here Hosea 122 to5 and
Yahweh has a contention with Judah and
will punish Jacob according to his ways
oops I got to charge the computer hold
on damn it
okay okay he will cause everything to
return to him according to his deeds in
the womb he took his brother heel see
this is now referring to Genesis 25 if
you guys read Genesis 25 24- 26 it says
they were Twins and when Esau came out
Jacob came out grabbing his heel So it's
talking about Jacob coming out of the
womb
right now watch
here and in his maturity he wrestled
with God okay where do we just read that
he wrestled God Genesis 32 right
right MH okay but who's the God he
wrestled with right here he wrestled
with the
angel and
prevailed it was the angel who is the
god that appeared as a man now watch
notice the name of the Angel he wept and
sought his favor whose favor the Angel's
favor he found him the angel at Beth
there he spoke with us even Yahweh the
god of hosts Yahweh is his name of
remembrance so notice
the angel is the god that he met and
wrestled with the angel is the god that
he saw at bethl and the angel's name is
Yahweh the god of
hosts no Esau was not going to receive
the blessing of the Covenant he missed
nothing but at the same time Esau was
worldly because he sold his Birthright
to Jacob for stew for you know but
anyway and I said Jacob gave him St
basically Jacob gave Isaac his favorite
dish so I'm giving you the gist now
remember he said that the angel he found
him where where did he find the angel at
bethl
right okay so the angel is the god he
saw at bethl
right so who is the god that appeared as
a man who wrestled with him the angel
right that's the one who becomes Jesus
Christ now he says he saw the angel at
bethl right yeah now watch
here you ready and then we'll go to your
next question because I've done a lot of
sessions on these Genesis 31 10- 13 Now
remind me of God's love remind me of
God's love for Leah because she was not
loved by Jacob watch how God honors her
and heals her broken heart now watch
here now it happened Genesis 31:10 to13
at the time when the flock were meting
Jacob speaking I lifted up my eyes and
saw in a dream and behold the male goats
which were mating were striped speckled
and modeled now notice this is before
Genesis 32 right MH now
notice the animals that are mating
having sex they were the male goats they
were meeting that had stripes on them
right they had Speckles on them modeled
right MH why here's the answer then the
angel of God said to me in a dream now
who appeared to him angel of God the
same angel that appeared as a man who's
the God he wrestle with it later right
mhm Jacob and I said here I am he said
lift up now your eyes and see that all
the male goats which are meting are
striped speckled and modeled for I've
seen all that leban has been doing to
you now notice the beauty of God guys
you need to listen the beauty of God the
mercy of God the compassion of God and
the knowledge of
God the angel is saying notice Jacob
only the goats that are striped speckle
modeled are mating because I've seen
what leban is doing to you I see that
leban is lying to you and oppressing you
why because leban said to Jacob any of
the cattle that has stripes Speckles and
mods this model will be yours which
means he's going to rob him because what
are the chances of goats coming out with
spots and Speckles so he's trying to
cheat him right yeah but what did Jesus
do
look what he did he goes I prevented the
goats that had no stripes or Speckles
and we're not modeled for mating and I'm
the one who caused only the strip
speckled modeled goats to mate because
now that will increase the percentage of
goats that will come out with stripes
speckle model increasing your portion
because I love you and I see what he's
doing to you and I've come to fight for
you
but you understand that shows you that
Jesus the angel Lord knows
genetics and he's in control of all life
he's the one controlling which of the
cattle will mate and which will
not do you see the love of God and the
mercy of God and the knowledge of God
and the glory of God and this is Jesus
right yeah you guys there catching it or
did you guys go to sleep are you seeing
here and look what he says why he's
doing it because if you read Genesis 28
10-22 there Jacob sees a ladder and he
sees Yahweh God on top and Yahweh tells
him I am with you and I will deliver you
and I'll protect you like I protected
your fathers Abraham Isaac and then
Jacob woke up and
said Jacob woke up and said surely God
is in this place this is the Gate of
Heaven and he called it bethl and then
he made a vow to God he goes God if you
bring me safely back to my father's home
I will give you a tent 10% of all I have
and you'll be my God so when he made
that bargain with God look what the
angel says see an angel speaking right
angel of God that was in Genesis 28
12-22 I am the god of bethl you remember
Jacob when you saw a dream you saw God
on the ladder you call that place bethl
because bethl means the house of God
Beth House of God I am the god of the
house of God where you anointed a pillar
and where you made a vow to me you
remember you made a vow to me that if I
protect you and bring you safely then
you'll make me your god well here I am
because I want to be your God here I am
because I want to save you here I am
because I love you and here I am because
I don't I don't want you to have any
other God but me so I'm now living up to
my bargain I am protecting you so now
you have to stay faithful and you
worship me alone as your God
I am the god of bethl where you anointed
a pillar where you made a vow to me now
arise leave this land and return to the
land of your kin he saying remember that
vow Jacob and I did a lot of series guys
go to my YouTube channel put an angel of
God I went through all these passages
hours of teaching so that's why I'm
rushing through it but also take enough
time to unpack it so the angel is
saying I heard your vow to me you told
me if I protect you and care for you and
fight for you you'll make me your God
and me alone and you'll worship no one
and I love you so much that I care for
you and I want you to know me because
I'm The Only God who can save so I'm
fighting for you now you're gonna have
to remain faithful to
me but this is the Angel
right I am the god of bethl that's the
same Angel appeared as a man whom he
wrestled right yeah and the one he said
that this is God I've seen God face to
face right mhm CU here he saw him in a
dream but in Genesis 32 he saw him in
real life not in a dream he showed up in
real
life yeah do you see the difference uhuh
so he's saying I seen him in a dream but
now I see him in real time appearing in
a human body a human body so real that I
can touch it and feel it and it can
actually
physically you know touch me and harm me
wow I actually saw God in real time not
just in a dream but here was a
dream you see who appeared to him
guys can I watch everyone and then on
top of that if you still don't think
this Angel is God not a creature who
becomes Jesus who's not the father
because he's the angel of the father
when he blesses his grandchildren
Ephraim and
Manassa look who he prays to and he
blessed Joseph and said Genesis 48156
May the god before whom my father's
Abraham Isaac walk notice the God who
has been my shepherd throughout my life
to this day the
angel who has redeemed me from all life
bless the boys notice who the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob is it's the
angel
so he's praying to the angel he's saying
this Angel is the god of my fathers
Abraham Isaac and they walked before him
and obeyed him this Angel is the god
who's been overseeing my life protecting
me this Angel is the god who's redeemed
me from all evil and now this is the
Angel who's The God Who blessed my
grandchildren right so did you get your
answer yeah so who is this this is Jesus
yeah and he's appearing in he didn't
become man he didn't take on a second
nature he appeared in a human body but
that body is so real he can eat in it
and you can touch it telling Jacob
enough but this is also a message to all
of us what's the
message the message is the life of
Christianity is a life of pain and
sacrifice don't think you're going to
have it easy this why Jesus said carry
your cross and follow me and deny
yourself because this life you will
suffer but if you suffer for me I
promise you you won't do it alone I'll
be with you I'll give you the power to
endure until you enter rest where you
suffer no more that's what he's teaching
him Jacob enough Jacob stop Jacob stop
running stop conniving stop being a
deceiver stop trying to plot in order to
escape your problems because when you
keep doing this and you're in sin I
cannot bless you in sin I hate sin man
up trust me face your problems and
endure because I'll give you the Grace
and if you do it my way then I can bless
you Jacob that's the message for all of
us see
it so there you go now I don't know if
that answered it but did you if you have
one more I'll take one more because
there are other people waiting yeah um